I'm not only so proud about what America
is doing even though it makes a lot of
mistakes but it's it's almost the last
Bastion um of freedom and my message to
my message is to every American I tell
you you are uh losing Europe you will be
the last man standing don't mess up
yourself uh but make sure that you
invest in your European allies and in
the in the in the correct European
allies no I'm not talking about the
about
the the French or the German or the
golden brown the UK leaders because um
they are demies they are giving up they
are appeasing they are chamberlains and
um at the end of the day you all have to
do the job well you know I appreciate
what you're saying very much and it's an
interesting perspective because uh we of
course uh in America consider there's a
great deal of media bias here also and
it's very hard to uh uh get an honest
discussion of this these issues uh here
and it's uh it's interesting to find
that well it can always be worse it to
you you'll see it's wor yes but uh the
the question actually is this that
you're you're saying that we need to
help our European allies and I think
that that's a very urgent thing that we
need to do but while you see the United
States fighting against Jihad terrorists
in Iraq and Afghanistan at the same time
when the president of the United States
says that Islam is a religion of Peace
when this has been echoed by both
presidential candidates when the
secretary of state has said the same
thing uh and they have ifar dinners in
the White House and so on uh do you
think that
uh
it's I mean I
suppose the situation in other words
seems very hopeless that the United
United States is going to awake awaken
to what's going on in I hope so this is
why U why I am here but I hope many more
European politicians uh will come here
or other people anti-islamic groups or
whatsoever
intellectuals like yourself journalists
um we should make the public aware that
uh uh on the long term um um it's not in
the interest of the United States
themselves it's not in the interest of
the
geopolitical stability and safeness if
America would use lope it would indeed
be the last man standing and I also
didn't understand the fact that the US
president today at 912 said America of
Islam is a is a religion of Peace this
is this is a totally ununderstandable
reflex of the political leader we
remember when in the streets of
Amsterdam few years ago as you know Mr
de van was slaughtered in the street
that one day later uh the prime minister
of the Netherlands and even the queen of
the Netherlands went to visit the mosque
uh and shook hands with moderate Muslims
as if we had any problems with moderate
Muslims instead of standing up and
saying what need needed to be said so
this is a ridiculous reflex and uh but I
think that also the American people in
the long run will not only see that
things will change and the islamization
will take part in the United States
itself I'm talking to people when I'm
here this week and I hear people saying
that did you hear that about the M being
built there did you hear that about the
AL food I mean there is also a growing
awareness in the United States and and
and I think by the uh government by the
administration there will be people
needed at least who will also think
about the uh political interest that
they will not let Europe be lost and
that they will stop advocating that for
instance what the United States
unfortunately is doing that turkey would
become a member of the European Union
this would be the most terrible and
worst idea when it comes to the
islamization of our of our continent and
I think that um um many Europeans and
people like yourself from the United
States should talk about it more to to
to the public uh to the leaders uh and
try to get the awareness and a sense of
urgency it's a matter of a sense of
urgency a little bit higher yes well
this is it seems that in both cases in
America and in Europe there is a gap as
you mentioned before between the elites
and the people who they are purporting
to govern it is the the difference is U
it's true that um the numbers are
different not only demographically but
also when you look at look at the
Netherlands we have uh 16 million
inhabitants one million of them are
Muslims it's one out of 16 it's not not
to be compared with the United States we
got our immigration from totally
different countries than you do so the
the difference is there but let me tell
you that um if um um um Europe will be
lost is if Israel will be lost um the
United the United States will be the
next Target yes of Islam and you have no
allies anymore and it will be very
difficult so it's far better to invest
in some preventive matters today than
when it's too late and your children and
grandchildren are already almost wearing
head scares walking through the streets
of Washington can you confirm something
I heard uh last year that the Brussels
City Council is already uh over 50%
musle I don't know that I'm I'm I'm not
Belgian I'm from the Netherlands uh I
don't know I know I know I know I know
you're not Belgian heard this because I
I heard it's very high uh Robert but I
don't exactly know if it's if it's a
majority
already that I don't know because if it
is or if it becomes such in other
European cities then obviously the
process is much harder to reverse it can
be voted down exactly and and listen
when I talk about the Netherlands our
two uh biggest cities major cities
Amsterdam and rdam if you look at the
people under the age of 18 the younger
people already today half of it is from
nonwestern origin mostly Muslim so and
this would be incredible imagine that
New York or or Denver or Washington that
half of the population under the age of
18 would be Muslim this is the future of
our society they win in demographics
they already have almost the majority
now when it comes to youngsters and and
we are they are representing as well an
enormous electoral Force why are they
pampered by in my country by the social
Democrats they are pampered because they
represent not they represent an enormous
voting force not only because the
leftish and the liberal invented the
concept of the Multicultural Society and
the cultural res relativism in the 60s
and the' 70s and they are not willing to
admit that they make make a mistake
sometimes politicians are almost like
humans not willing to admit a mistake
but they have they have a big interest
in it are those phots we have had
municipality elections in rdam where the
former party of Mr fine was very strong
where they lost the elections because of
the Muslim vote it's already happening
there it is it is it is
there